spent weeks in an intensive care unit
and alhamdulillah she pulled through
milesand is going to be a doctor when
she grows up
[Music]
thanks to your help and support bilisan
is back on her feet
and able to walk once again
this is the difference
a donation of only 500 pounds can make
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
may allah bless you guys inshallah and
welcome back to my channel brothers and
sisters skepta skepta is somebody that i
used to listen to in my jahilia like
there were some of his tracks that were
actually quite
nice and i really enjoyed listening to
them he had one version specifically uh
which was a popular turkish thing called
tarkan
it was called kiss kiss or something all
those lies i needed this little mix
remix version i mean i used to listen to
this kind of stuff you know and you know
back in the days music played a massive
role in my life never did drugs never
did alcohol but music was that high that
i would get so i was his fan i can say
you know i was his ex-fan you know but
skepta is uh somebody obviously who's in
the music industry um he's now i think
america i think even does something with
drake along those lines but anyways so
he made a tweet uh not he made an
instagram story which was sent to me and
by the way guys samantha john is going
to bring be bringing a brilliant video
on the same topic on a different angle
do not forget to watch that inshallah
i'm going to tag that inshallah as soon
as he releases it so this is what he
said here's the following
so i woke up this morning happy and full
of joy can't stop crying kissing my
teeth lol
such a beautiful month yeah everything i
search for in psychedelics i found by
fasting one of the main things is i used
food to suppress my emotional stress and
anger
and anger granted i have learned these
bad
i i've learned these bad traits from
somewhere somewhere but still it's my
issue and i have to see my body about it
i have to see somebody about it sorry
i'm so thankful and will definitely be
fasting again even on a regular days
simply because it is so humbling love to
my brothers and sisters that are fasting
for ramadan mubarak okay that's very
interesting okay this was a very very
profound if you let's dive sickness one
by one now it's very interesting number
one i woke up this morning happy and
full of joy we like to hear that you
know it's about positivity alhamdulillah
like as and i want you guys to send it
to skepta please please send us a script
uh that we should always be optimistic
and full of joy this is a part of us
like the prophet peace be upon him said
that allah is to his servants how he
thinks of him how you think of allah is
how you're going to find allah can't
stop crying now for a grown man who's in
the rap who is you know you can say
maybe alpha male whatever it may be
for him to admit that he's he cries is a
big thing it shows that he's in a place
that he doesn't want to be in for a man
to express this as you know we have the
stigma etc we have to be men we can't
cry that's the reason we have the
highest rates for suicide with men so
now that's one thing
such a beautiful month now what's very
very interesting to me was the following
okay he could have fast any time there
are a lot of muslims that fast but he
specifically chose ramadan why which is
very interesting okay because fasting in
ramadan is not just something that um we
individually do it's a whole thing
that's done around the world it's a
movement it's it's something that is
prescribed to us like allah says in the
quran that has been prescribed to the
people before us and it's prescribed to
us as well and fasting is not just what
you abstain from food and muta because
the prophet salallahu said allah is not
in near of the one who fuss with his
tongue i mean with this the food and
drink and he backbites he slanders his
stools does all kinds of other stuff we
fast with our eyes with our ears with
our tongue not back bites and others etc
so it's very very interesting because if
i'm not mistaken he's around a group of
people who are staunch christians you
know um so for him to pick ramadan it's
quite profound you know it might be that
he found that connection and we ask
allah subhanahu wa tala to guide him and
we always say this if if kept us
watching this
only allah says in the quran
only in the remembrance of your lord
would you find peace
and then in another verse allah said and
if you forget my remember should have a
depressed life skepta what that means is
the following we are programmed to find
happiness only with the memories of god
no woman no car no house no money no
land no holidays nothing is going to
replace that and every time we achieve
these things get the most beautiful
woman in your life whatever me and i'm
sure there's a lot of girls around you
houses cars money every time you reach
the peak of that you still are looking
you know what that is that is your heart
seeking god almighty and a connection
with him and we think by replacing it
with the money cars girls cars or
whatever it may be that that will happen
no because once you give that to the
heart the heart rejects it because it
says i don't want that that is not my
nourishment just as if you have bad food
your body rejects if you vomit it out
because it's not the stomach is saying
this is not good for me and that is the
same way the heart is rejecting it and
only in the happiness only in the
remembrance of you god do you find
happiness i know people that don't have
money they don't have anything but let
me tell you something they have this
deep inner happiness in them you know
why because once you have that sweetened
sweetness of faith of worshiping the one
true god and not associating partners
with him and describing what he has done
for you and giving the credit to jesus
or muhammad or moses or abraham peace be
upon all of them but associate in
associating no partners with him and
directly
worshipping him because when you took
part in the ramadan fasting you know you
hopefully what you've done is that you
are doing it obviously for you it might
be
not based on worship reasons but based
on other reasons but what that shows you
is that even if that brought you joy
just imagine if you did that for the
sake of god how powerful that would be
so skip that look at the end of the day
i don't know if you like to reach out to
me and that's it before and even if you
do i'll make it very clear i'm not here
to be like oh skip reach out for me if
you genuinely need some information
privately i can try my best to give any
information amir i'm not here to clout
et cetera or skepta message me no if you
sincerely i can even direct you to
people who are much more fast superior
than me uh in these kind of knowledges
when it comes to islam so that's all i
wanted to say and another thing one just
one to finish on is that look he has
access to money he has access to all
kind of girls girls are probably find
themselves at him
house money tours
just imagine
for him to say i'm going to fast that's
deep bro that's steve that's telling you
telling us that none of these things
genuinely make him happy the fact of
fasting and abstaining from them and
saying no i'm going to fast
shows you something very deep guys it
shows you that as human beings we do not
get more happy by having everything that
we want rather that cause us to be more
unhappy and that's the reason why there
are barriers and legislation god
almighty is put in place as these
protocols
that make us be more appreciative to the
things that we don't have because in
ramadan we abstain from our wives and
food and stuff that we can regularly
have we can't do it it's just appreciate
and like they say
it's only once you lose something that
you appreciate it and
inshallah i've skipped that comes to
islam bro you can seek those in rightful
ways you know be the money the cause etc
in the rightful ways and even women you
are allowed to marry after uh four wives
yeah let me be honest it's a man of high
influence you know high value man what
you call it the limit is four of course
but those things can be done and
practice in the rightful ways um by
giving the rights of those women as well
uh by marrying them etc but that's all i
wanted to say guys hopefully you guys
benefited share this with skepta tag him
inshallah if you want to watch it if not
hope you guys benefited and do not
forget to watch smarter janna's angle on
this inshallah which is very profound
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh